well good evening and welcome members
officers and those members of the public
here at the meeting and those joining us
virtually item one on our agenda this
evening apologies for absence thank you
apologies re from councelors Christie
councelor cord councelor heel and
councelor Smith thank you
kiry item two is to confirm the minutes
of the last meeting which was the 11th
of
December I'll just run through them Page
by Page starting with page
four
five
six seven
[Music]
nine
15 that's Bron page
16 the minutes of page 16 in no way what
happened
[Music]
at in fact due to the fact that you made
a rather demeaning and belittling remark
about me that was personally um directed
toward my domestic circumstances were
holy inappropriate I was somewhat
disconcerting and couldn't follow the
situation but the facts are that after
the motion was
seconded there was a discussion at the
top of the room which could not be heard
at the other end particularly by me and
people below me councelor bat stood up
and the chair appeared to have a private
conversation with him which could not be
heard there was obviously some kind of P
trading going on down there my husband
had seconded the motion and according to
the Constitution if a motion is proposed
Dy proposed legally proposed and
seconded then it has to be voted on
unless I withdrew the motion which I did
not or that an amendment is made and
that Amendment had to be voted on none
of those things happen this was a
serious breach of the Constitution a
really ser serious breach ignoring um
a61
a66 a68
a69 and a and b these were all ignored
by the chair who's supposed to be an
experienced
chairperson the motion was not withdrawn
I did not agree to it being withdrawn it
was just Shell by The Chair by his own
agenda which has nothing to do with the
Constitution and that is why it's on the
agenda again today and the fact of the
matter is that if this is the kind of
standard we have at this Council where
the chair makes a personal remark about
me which I took serious offense to and
then totally ignores breaches the
Constitution then obviously we're in
dire need of some kind of remedy to the
situation and obviously we'll come to
that later in the meeting but the fact
of the matter is that that those minutes
do not reflect this
completely
um dismissal of the Constitution a
neglect of the way the rules of debate
should be conducted so is this a
precedent is this what we setting now is
a precedent that we ignore the
Constitution from now on that we just do
what we like is that what this Council
has come to surely
not
I was that page 16 I believe it is Page
17 point on there about the date of the
next standards meeting and we weren't
sure at the time in the last meeting
what the date was it didn't it isn't in
the fact in January it's the 28th of
February just a point of clarification
chair thank you thank you I was going to
clarify that but than for doing that
thank you page 17
18 uh and 19 I beg to move those minutes
someone like to Second them Mr Newton
seconded all in favor please
show
[Music]
against
and
[Music]
abstentions that's 24 three against and
six
abstentions Carri thank
you moving on then to the action list
Pages 20 to
21 all actions are now
complete
[Music]
moving then on to item four public
contribution we have no public speakers
this
evening Declarations of interest is item
number five or you all know the score by
now if you have a an item you have to
declare please do so the appropriate
time item six agreement of agenda items
between part one and two for our part
two items this evening presor
Thomas I'd like to move that this is
discussed in public um I don't see why
this matter should be discussed with
confidentiality confidence um without
going into any detail I believe there's
two elements one of it is the
negotiations which the council were
involved in which as I understand it are
now complete on the basis that they
failed um the other part of it is that
involves a site that the council already
owns so I don't see why there's any need
for this to be discussed in private
thank you um had a conversation about
this very item earlier on today and the
the item you referred to as complete is
is by no means complete it's still
ongoing there is the expectation that we
will still be pursuing that item so
that's why it has to be in part two if
it isn't in part two then we can't
discuss it and have to be withdrawn from
the agenda but the actual the the other
part of the
recommendation um concerns site that Tor
ownes can we not discuss that in
public that one we probably could but
it's one you know it's what it's one
agenda item it's not two separate agenda
items with my
understanding it seems a way of hiding
things by linking the
two well I mean if if members want to
have a full and Frank discussion about
the the item that's on the agenda
clearly we need to do them in part
because we we can't do it um with the
public in the room and particularly as
we're on on on YouTube so I think you
know In fairness to allow everyone to
have have have their say and and need to
be in part to that's my understanding on
the point if caner made a proposition
can I second I happy to move
that that's Le
[Music]
yeah in this in part two item there's
some commercially sensitive information
the two sites under that will be under
discussion are linked in the report you
can't separate one from the other that's
why it's in part yeah there will be an
opportunity of the lat to dat when it
can all go out into the public domain
but not current because it does affect
the commercial site and commercially
sensitive information
okay well councelor Brenton once said to
me I don't believe in an awful lot but I
do believe in democracy then we'll been
proposed and
[Music]
second but it has been proposed and has
been seconded so we need to take a vote
on
that propos on a second for the
recommendations but we' got exactly than
we take councel Thomas's first that we
hear the discussion in part one it's
been seconded by Council Brenton so
let's be clear this is to hear
everything in part one and not go into
part two so show off hands in support of
councelor Thomas's
motion and
against
extensions 74 22 against and one
exension we don't need to take a vote on
the
other item seven is to consider
corespond go for chair I have nothing in
particular no
chair item eight uh is to receive a
presentation from Katherine Allen
director of strategy for NHS Royal Dev
University healthcare NH NHS Foundation
trust it's a bit of a title but um to
you Katherine and you you have a 10
minute slot for your presentation so I
was going to split it between my myself
and the that's fine you can have five
minutes each if you wish thank you I'll
try and do it in three so thank you so
much for inviting me can you hear me
okay quite loud is this magic thing
gonna move as I speak or do I have to do
can I just before you start you can have
a few seconds after um we've only got
the one screen working right we've got a
technical issue with the screen behind
you so I'm afraid those that are on this
side of the room we're going to have to
neck a little bit to have a look I do
apologize
not part of the presentation but more
can
be the slid em Brown
to I just say next SL say next perfect
next slide please so um I'm here just to
really talk to you about um some changes
to the structure of the NHS uh I'm going
to try and keep my acronyms to the
lowest possible level but really the
sense of what I'm trying to convey is
just we have a we have a redefined
purpose in the NHS and locally that's
come down to to um mean um we've got a
we've got some foces sorry some new
organizations that we are working within
um and and I think one of the key things
uh to point out to this is we've got uh
integrated Care Systems that were
founded in legislation in 2022 and Devon
is a whole integrated care system and
within within that there is four
purposes and there are some that would
make sense some that's all about
improving the health and wellbeing of
the population but I'd just like to draw
your attention to the fourth one which
is about the NHS responsibility in the
broader social and economic development
we understand that you need healthy
people to be working and healthy
families to be
educating to to deliver their to those
potential so there is a shift in
government policy about the purpose of
the NHS if I could have the next slide
please uh you'll be really familiar with
this map obviously it's Devon North
North Devon and torridge are put into
what's called a local care partnership
and again once you take the four
purposes of the ICS is the designed to
provide the structures to work in
Partnership so the NHS is working in
partnership with all of the councils the
voluntary pair sectors um and local body
such as yourself to really think about
what is driving Health inequality uh
poor health poor economic prospects in
your local community and what can we do
together to resolve some of these things
now I know Tor is leveling up ship loing
up boards and and all sorts of things
happening and they're targeting levels
of deprivation in the country so there's
opportunities here because the NHS is
place is being asked to think outside of
its barriers of the hospital wall
thinking what's happening in people's
lives so um if I could have the next two
slides I'll skip on from that you've got
these slides I don't need to talk about
the detail but I think what's striking
is in thinking about the IC and in
thinking about how the NHS in Devon work
and what are our priorities there are
loads of things on this slide that
you'll expect to see people's Health
getting people treated um quickly but
there's climate change there is housing
affordability and quality there is um uh
sorry there's there's education training
and skills and these are things that
would probably have never appeared on an
NHS strategy a couple of years back but
the point is in policy terms they're now
being recognized as absolute enablers to
a healthy population and I think
um some of the things that I talked to
Steve quite a lot about is we've sort of
kind of opened our doors really in the
NHS we are here we know we can't solve
some of these things on our own um and
so what I've done in the next view sides
is just to help you see where our
strategies are line where are where are
where we have common purpose in thinking
about the health and wellbeing of our Lo
population if I slip on if you click on
to another side it's brilliant I love
having this support um I've just put
some blue boxes up here which say the
top blue are the what are the priorities
for enous Devon as it expresses itself
and then the bottom blocks are the ones
that um we think we you know are
enablers to achieving that and if you
could just flick through where I think
our past align are in now in yellow so
Community Development really resilient
communities employment for those not in
education um apprenticeship on paid
carers Health protection of our
immunization the measles um the measles
outbreaks at the moment will affect us
all in terms of the working age
population school age population how do
we give our population healthy housing
is particularly an issue for us at the
moment um Sahara will talk to you in a
minute about about um how this is
impacting us but housing for star is a
massive issue we're already one of the
most remote hospitals in the country
attracting staff and being able to find
housing for those sta is a massive
problem for us providing the transport
to get them to their house to our
hospitals is another issue and then you
overlay that with patients the patient
Journeys coming into our car Parks
trying to access Healthcare it's massive
so housing I just I've rested on that a
long time because I think you'll get the
sense that's a massive issue for us in
the NHS um skip on I think there's a
couple more yeah sustainability of our
hospital again so har will talk to you
about about that but what we mean by
that is is not only the environmental
impact but also the sustainability of
our services in the most rural area in
in the
UK If you could SK keep skipping on so
in the enablers I think again we've got
um a couple of things where we I've
noticed you have got these priorities
and we need we need you to be working on
these prioritize priorities if I can put
it so LLY we need we need to make we've
got a net zero challenge in the NHS
we've got a Workforce challenge we've
got Health inequalities that we have
that are wider
um and so on and so on oh sorry and
we've got a digital model of care that
actually we need your help with as well
we need broadband and we need to think
about how we get access to people
respective of their digital
literacy so that's hopefully a snapshot
of where I think um what the NHS Deon
strategy is if I move on I've also taken
Liberty of looking at your strategy too
and similar um similar if you could
click through um all of our priorities
align you see that we need a viiz
economy we need a world class
environment to attract people and to um
be sustainable in we need a balanced
housing market to support local health
services and we need really strong and
inclusive communities that support each
other and a strong so and and and and
that I could go on but I think I hope
I'm making the point to you that we
can't provide NHS services that are
sustainable without the support of
really good local Council plans and and
a real vision for our community so I I I
just here really to say can we please
work together and my last slide before I
hand over to my colleague is um these
this so we've condensed de so we provide
North de District Hospital as well as
all of the Community Hospitals in in
North de that now we've merged with Aran
East and we' we've worked out that we
have four four real strategic objectives
we need to collaborate and work in
partnership with with bodies like
yourself we need to provide a place to
work we need really look after our staff
because their jobs to look after all of
you and our community we need to recover
our waiting lists which is hard as you
as you probably hear in the news it's
it's challenged and we need to we need
to innovate and continually challenge
ourselves to modernize the NHS so those
are those are our snapshot objective
right now position we're in at the
moment if I could just move on to the
Bott one last slide um I I have just
summarized you where I think our main
areas of of work in Partnership together
are people's health is only 20% of of of
influenced by the NHS the rest of it is
our
community we we really we really need a
housing strategy I was really interested
in the minute minutes from your December
meeting you also think you need a
housing strategy and we're really ready
to help in provide whatever data you
need to help make that strongest
strategy possible and Lobby on our on
the dev and's behalf infrastructure is a
really interesting one um digital
infrastructure public transport and
those of you who've been looking at the
news know that we are getting quite a
lot of Ang from our staff about par
about car parking you know some of them
are legitimate concerns if we had public
transport that worked we wouldn't be we
wouldn't be having quite some much
difficulty so um I could go on but
there's employment environment and
economy as well we need all of this to
sustain Health Services you need all of
this to sustain businesses and reir so
um I will stop talking I'm really happy
to take questions at the end so I'm
going to hand over to
Sahara through the future Hospital C has
left me two minutes thank
we on the you can read those up I think
what I'd like to do is just take this
opportunity just to give you a very
quick insight into where the program for
the new hospital developments at now
because many of you would have read
different bit so maybe listen to us talk
I know some people here came to Lord
Mark and
presentation it's a very tricky place to
be at the moment because the government
intention which was publicly expressed
back in 2019 is taking longer to deliver
than we might all have hope I think
that's probably a summary and with the
intervention of some of the other
variables both the pandemic the rack
hospitals raing inflation it's not been
an easy time to run a massive building
program we locally have to focus on what
matters to us so what we have done is
has tried as much as possible to work
with the new hospital program while
they've been trying to work out how
they're going to deliver this massive
program and focus on our local
priorities and those feed directly into
what Katherine just talked about so we
need to house our staff we need to
ensure that we can sustain local
Services we spent a year after the
merger developing a joint clinical
strategy and what that basically said
was local urgent and Emergency Care has
to be delivered locally in North Devon
that's through ndh and that we would
deliver care closer to home where we can
in our communities which has been our
commitment to continuing to maintain and
look at ways of growing services in the
future working with our Primary Care
networks who are an absolute partner in
delivering care outside of the hospital
itself and then finally obviously
elective care recovering some of these
waiting lists all of that in the face of
growing population the original
predictions we did in 2020 21 said we
would run out of capacity by
2728 and that's what I told all of you
um it's a little bit worse than that
probably going to run out in about 25 26
because the sheer impact of the pandemic
on elected care the delays it's
introduced in people accessing care and
therefore the number of people who've
toppled into crisis and need more Urgent
Care means it's taking a number of years
now to catch up on that backlog not
months so all of that is the scenario
against which we're working so we've
developed an offer which we're
negotiating now with the new hospital
program they have said we can have more
money than they originally said we can
redevelop a lot more of our site which
is great news but we don't want to do it
all at once because we need to
prioritize and focus so our staff
housing first and our critical estate
our theaters our ICU our Women's and
Children's our Universal Services we
want those built by 2030 and then we
will happily continue to redevelop the
site using the other monies working with
our community estate as well to make
sure we deliver the most sustainable
offer but we think that's the key and it
tenal to put that in the pack for you
but I thought this would be a better use
of my two minutes of time really happy
to take any
questions thank you for that go you've
got your
FR so cine can I just ask you you call
it the new hospital program is it going
to be a new hospital or is it going to
be refurbishment on distance s thank you
that sounds like a question for me um we
actually use the word Redevelopment and
the reason we do that is because we're
not going to pull down all of the old
buildings we will replace a significant
chunk the new build as we hypothecate it
now although we haven't done the designs
yet will encompass large chunks of our
hospital care services but we are hoping
still to keep the main tower simply so
we can maintain offices admin training
development and outpatient services
still so I can't call it a new hospital
because that would be a new build on a
new site but I can call it a major
Redevelopment of our existing
site yeah thank you yeah thank you I
think it Katherine who spoke first um
I'm a huge fan of preventative um
measures in community and I was very
interested in your statistic of 20%
80% um I've worked a lot in the
voluntary sector to get people moving
activity Etc over that time come to
realize that there's an I feel there's
an elephant in the room which is diet um
and as a strategy I wonder I might be
being a bit too um prescriptive in
saying diet but how how that fits in
with the NHS and and all its Partners
you know is Diet the elephant in the
room and maybe you could come back on
that idea and there are quite a few
elephants using your term and we call
them um risky behaviors or modifiable
behaviors so there smoking in there
alcohol obesity is one of them and I
think um the reason where we get into
this space is because we know clinician
to patients has a far more inform itial
influence on that person's Behavior than
perhaps giving them a you know a diet
card or a recipe card whatever so we
know we have a part to play now we but
we tend it's if if you call that
prevention then maybe you know I think
prevention in terms of some of this
happens in childhood and happens with
your peers and your the way you are you
know your social situation so I think
we've all got a role in prevention
actually but no scientific research says
that patients are far more influenced
and will give up smoking will eat
healthier when the clinician takes the
time to talk to them about it so and
clinicians know
that yeah it goes very quickly come
back and um yeah thank you for that
answer you're right it's not just
prevention um but I think there's a
narrative in the public that activity is
the answer I think that's an unfair one
on a lot of people and actually diet is
the first answer and activity reinforces
that and I wonder whether I don't hear
that message um enough I think um our
experience shows that if you focus on
what matters to me the byproduct of
seeing your family more or friends is
that you have walked there or that you
have gone out for a trip in a park that
that's activity but but the point is
they're doing the thing that makes them
mentally healthy as well as physically
healthy and I I don't think you can just
say to everyone you must be healthier I
think you have to go with what do they
want what what motivates people to live
healthier lives and happier lives and I
think that's the key and the volun
sector that we work the volary sector
organizations that we work with to take
that real what matters to me approach
and I think we learn a lot from them
because quite often we see people coming
through our service again and again I'm
thinking of through our Ed a AE at North
Devon and we don't fix their problem
because their problem is social and
their problem is not something that we
can physically fix with me with physical
health intervention
C Le side up and then C thank you chair
I was interested to hear you mentioning
about
housing um is it a proposal that you're
going to provide your own housing over
in North
de so there's and so how much housing
were you looking for yes senior people
who work in the Health Service so um
initially the first phase is focused
primarily actually on the acute s itself
we have for a number of years probably
more than 40 now had short-term
residential accommodation which serves
as you know three purposes visiting
clinicians short-term residences uh
incoming staff who need somewhere to
bridge uh that's what we're going to
replace first of all however we are
taking a business case um through our
boards which looks more widely at how we
can work with Partners out in the public
sector the private sector to provide
more housing has ring fenced keyw worker
accommodation so that we can start to
bridge that Gap um that we see in the
marketplace where there is short-term
rentals for people who aren't yet in the
position to be able to buy their own
property so a little bit of both but the
initial Focus for us as an NHS provider
has to be short-term accommodation for
NHS
staff m l um I was just interested um
just for me my elephant in the room or
whatever is social care because we hear
a great deal about the problem one of
the problems for the NHS is you know
backing up because social care isn't in
place and the um the presentation it was
linking with various things seen or
maybe I wasn't paying attention I
apologize because it was a great
presentation um to focus much on on on
on the social care aspect that is great
or not helping with the backlog for the
NHS and I just wondered if you were also
liasing somehow back yeah so daily it's
in the NHS Devon strategy about carers
and social care but at operationally we
are leasing with social care daily
because you know we have patients that
are ready to be discharged and we work
with our colleagues to discharge them on
time you're right there are sometimes
delays but um it's got better recently
um but you know we still have a uh do we
value this Workforce enough and I think
we could all we could all I think you
know everyone I I think it's a matter of
public record that we need a social care
strategy at a national policy level you
know we're doing what we can in the
meantime councelor penon and then
councelor Andrew thank you chair
hopefully that'll be the last one I'd
like to thank you for your work you do
and the hard you had so thank you very
much for everything both that exitor now
we have to say as well as North Deon and
it's a bit hard for us up here we have
to travel to exra all the time but thank
you for all in both hospitals patient
initiated initiative
followup a little bit concerning because
um my wife has worked in the Health
Service before and we've helped one or
two do um FaceTime get treatment for
cancers what's going to happen to those
patients who don't initiate their
followup and what safety measures are
you going to put in place for those who
don't have the technology or the
understanding given that we have an
aging population to actually get
involved to do what you're asking us to
do what safety measures for those who s
through the net effectively I might have
to come back to you are
you I was going say that so just there
is a transforming out patient work
stream in the hospital which is looking
at just this issue because you can't
have a one siiz spit so you're
absolutely right and even through the
pandemic we could see that so whilst a
lot of virtual consultations and so on
took place it was not for everybody I
have an 89 year old mother I can tell
you where that's going to go and start
with so we absolutely have to operate
number of different channels for
Consulting with people and for working
with them that group is looking at how
we safely run both the process of
clinical trios to decide who is eligible
to be somebody who can follow up
themselves and that's done in
consultation with patients not
separately but they're also looking at
how they look at the different Pathways
because not all pathways are suitable
either so I probably just want to
reassure you it's not our field of
expertise but the clinicians for whom it
is are very about getting this right
Thank you very much chair thank you
you please just wondered um I have a
friend who lived in a different area to
this but they went to the hospital in
May um early May for two weeks and they
came out because of lack of social Care
on christas Eve could you assure me that
that could not happen here no um no no
because it might have happened but it
but you tend to plan discharges with
people and if they want to leave on
Christmas Eve they leave on Christmas
Eve if they want to leave at 4 in the
morning and it's safe they will leave at
4 in the morning do you know what I mean
so he believe in me oh okay but there
was no social care to got it okay sorry
yeah I hadn't correlated the two sorry
that is the long two weeks
um I don't think there's anyone I have
to get back to you I don't think there
is anyone who has L stayed that long in
North Deon Good Very occasionally with
the you get very complex people I'm not
saying that's about your friend but but
occasionally they need have the higher
needs and we have to wait for a
placement somewhere else but but that
sounds
extreme sorry can I just add just
because we kind of B through the outut
hospital I if you go on the world Deon
website there is an our future Hospital
email address so if anyone's got any
questions or noting this goes on YouTube
at a public record if anybody wants to
get in touch please feel free well
that's our go for us
next councelor Mrs Brenton thank you
chair um you mentioned um one of the key
challenges is the mental health issues
across the whole population we all know
that that straddles many many different
aspects of people's Health um what is is
your connection or have you got any
Community involvement with d County
Council because I I'm sure you know that
we're struggling up here to keep our n
Center open in bford and of course the
same is true in h and barn and this is a
community initiative that has been very
very helpful to mental health in our
area and has helped some people to
prepare themselves to go back into work
when they haven't been working for a
long time um it seems that Devon County
Council has some initiatives in the
pipeline but we don't know what they are
and they're being very very Coy about
what is going to replace these very
valuable and worthwhile link centers so
do you have any um initiative or contact
with them that will help to
establish an improvement in the
situation with mental health commity in
our area
thank you so as a stakeholder we're
briefed obviously by the by the dev
County Council team uh and we I think
I'm writing saying I'm not too close in
it the consultation is still ongoing and
I think from our perspective what we've
heard and what we been we' made sure is
that we've encouraged people who are
going to be impacted by these proposals
to make sure their voice is heard and in
particular there's there's impacts on
the children vulnerable children I think
within that as well so uh with we are a
partner we have no we have no influence
we have uh we are able to U submit our
views to the consultation um but I don't
have any insight I'm afraid you'd have
to ask Deon County Council about where
they are in their stages of consultation
you're absolutely right it mental health
is really important I think the the the
hypothesis of this consultation is how
do you deliver it and how do you deliver
it to such a community like North de and
college thank
you right well thank you both ladies for
presentation very
informative thank
you okay moving forward item nine on
your agenda is Southwest water update
and is to receive a presentation from
Southwest water Richard Price group
chief engineer and director and Ian Lake
head of the vanifer services can I just
say before we actually get the uh this
presentation going Southwest water are
arranging a further presentation with
Helen Smith or um planning manager in
this building at a date to be confirmed
hopefully in early March and it'll be a
meeting with North Devon Council and
torage so I'm sure we've probably got
those are the one questions that we'd
like to bombard these gentlemen with but
they can't really go into specifics the
the reason they're here tonight is if
you if recall counselor coun Peter
Christie um asked the question with
regard to planning and the the answer
that sass water appear to gave each
stand there a planning application goes
goes in particularly a substantial one
so over to you guys for the presentation
thank you great thank you thank you very
much chairman counselors uh so I'm going
to do a brief introduction and I think
we within the 10 minute as well and then
my colleague Ian will take you through
the slides and and you've all got a copy
of the slides and this is all focus on
how we're strengthen our relationship
and the planning process with your
officers and with the planning committee
uh and there's a session with the
offerors back in November there's
another one coming the off and then as
the chair has just described we've got a
a deeper dive session with the planning
committee coming up as well so that'll
be that's really good and for us it's
you know at Southwest Walter it's really
important because we want to facilitate
the growth in the region we want to
enable tourism and at the same time
obviously protect the wonderful
environment that we live in uh so that's
really right at the heart of what what
we what we do and you probably noticed
as well that we've just submitted our
business plan uh to our regulator offat
for the next five years starting 2025
that's more than doubling our investment
up to 2.8 billion for one 1.4 billion in
this current 5e period so there's a
massive amount of work going on and
we've engaged with many of our three and
a half million customers and they've
helped inform our business plan and
there are four key priorities ities in
that plan the first one having
sustainable resilient and great water
quality drinking water quality the
second one reducing storm overflows and
pollution the third one uh championing
Net Zero and promoting environmental
Gaines with all tree planting and so on
reversing carbon emissions and then the
final one is making sure that our plan
is Affordable importantly affordable for
all of our customers so there's a
massive amount of work going on so I'm
going to get in to take you to the
slides to say you've got them in your PA
and then we'll L around the questions so
over to
you before we apologize just notic the W
soize for
that um the first please thank you so
apologies slightly wordy slide but what
we're trying to do today is Swit said
just the focus really on the plan we've
got a lot of things we'd like to share
with you as a counselor we certainly do
that going forward but um we um as as
you're aware on statut consti the
planning process but that doesn't mean
that we don't um um engage in that
process and we we we always try to do
that we look at something like um so
I've got a small team um working with me
as part of the wi team we look at
something like 30,000 applications per a
year um when we do that we're looking at
a number of things so we try to
understand whether our networks can
support that new development um we've
got some obligations as a
business within the water industry to
actually make sure our investment plans
support that growth so so again we need
to make sure that forwardly looking
investment plans continue to support
that gra um we want to make sure that we
um continue to protect the
environment so anyone obviously we've
some big challenges in the the
environment space at the minute we're
working very hard on that we Mak some
real good inows in terms of making some
fantastic improvs but we've got an awful
lot more we still need to do in that
space so we want to make sure that we
can continue to do that and then the
last thing we look at is make sure that
our infrastructure and whether that be
water M whether sewer um you know is
going to be protected from the
development so we're not going to be
damaged during instruction or it's going
to be our future maintenance is be
limited in terms of of accessing going
forward as um as as Richard said you
know we we we've recognized following
the following the feedback and we you
know obious saw C Chris's comments um
you know and and that caused us and
prompted us to just reflect in terms of
the way that we were doing things
internally we've already started some
work internally I've I've held um one
workship with a number of others be done
internally with a number of different
departments across the business um to
really reflect in terms of how we how we
um assess planning applications how we
assess the future growth and we continue
to do that and we're also very keen you
know and hopefully this will be the
start of a much stronger relationship
ourselves we've also reached out to all
the other planning authorities on the
same basis to try and make sure that we
strengthen those those
links thank you um this a very quick
slide and just just a couple of examples
really but um just to share with you and
these are all available on our website
so so all these documents are are
available so these are just just a small
um examp of our some of our more
strategic documentation so we've got our
drainage and Waste Water Management
plans that looks in a strategic look
ahead um and then takes a number of
things so it will look at growth it'll
look at our environmental performance
it'll link up our investment programs to
ensure that we're targeting the right
things on the other side of things in
terms of all resources been very aware
some of the challenges we faced at the
end of last summer um we've got our
draft and it's only in draft the minute
because we're going through a
consultation process with that we've got
our draft water source management plan
which is a very similar thing around
making sure that we've got sufficient
Water Resources going forward to make
sure we to to meet and then there are
some other more technical docents on
there so things pollution strategy and
as I say they're all available on our
websites
um like to look at those just underline
that very quickly in terms of strategic
priorities necessarily with them all um
you know we've got a water fit program
so our waterfit program is reducing CSO
scales so we' seen a lot of that in the
in in the Press inad of CSO scales um
we're investing um between now and 2025
330 million pound in terms of reducing
the average bills um per location to 20
per year or below 20 per year and that's
not you know where we want to finish but
obviously we've got to do this in a in a
in a joint approach moving on from that
we've got another 900 million pound near
marked up until 2030 to continue that
Journey um to really get to the point
where we're heading to try and get down
to below um 10 spills per year by 2014
so death with the government they the
industry at Target of50 to get to that
point we are trying to outform that
about 10 years we' accelerated our
investment to make that happening on the
Water Resources side as I say it's R
making sure that we've got um not only
the Water Resources but also understand
the impact we've Tak lot of water from
rivers in terms of so we got to
understand how that impacts the
environment to make sure we can do that
we got a plan that that joins that
up so just very quickly um in terms of
our our approach so um you know under
the current rules got to say developers
have a right to connect to the nearest
sewer and the nearest multim so they've
got a right to do that um but um you
know obviously we as a staty Undertaker
also have an obligation um through our
commitment to to facilitate gr we' got
to make sure that we we work with
developers work with planning
authorities but also make sure our
investment streams line up on that basis
ultimately it's for the for the
developer to present the drainage
strategy for their site to make sure
obviously it won't have a detrimental
impact on the environment but often we
will have engage certainly the large
National house builders will often of
engaged with them we have clear count
relationships with them to make sure we
can work with them to help them to try
and develop some of those ideas before
argu it com to the planning process but
then it's up to us then so where we've
got these these these these commitments
it's then up to us to make sure that our
investment can meet that um and we and
effectively it's funded through an
infrastructure charge developers would
pay an infrastructure charge at the time
of connection and that goes towards
making sure that we can invest in the
networks and do the things that we need
to do to make um you know the capacity
available um I said just now we look at
C 30,000 necessarily C that um and we
use an internal supply demand tool so a
tactical demand based tool um that we
put the development into it and then
give us some indications around whether
or not we've got the theu support um
there are times that we flag up you know
sort of an Amber on that basis and we
will use them we've got some specialist
internal modeling teams we also use
external Consultants to help us on that
on that
Journey
so just in terms of just a few things um
and um in terms of things we're looking
for so ultimately and and we come back
to the environmental performance we
envir performance of our seage networks
um generally speaking um they are driven
by cirace so when we have SPS not in all
cires the majority of C driven by
because that's what ultim tech be most
of our networks have got the capacity
required for f drainage um but it's when
we have the wet weather events and storm
events um the surface water that legy
often a legacy surface water we connect
to our system and that's what it
takes so consequently you know while we
talk about combined sew when we talk
about fwer surface water sewer i b sewer
which is a mix of the two um we've been
for some time now um ensuring that we
keep those things separate so we will we
will separate on site we work with the
developers and such to make sure they um
you know the the okay to just put their
service into our networks because that's
what process and challenge with we have
what we call the surface course
hierarchy um and ultimately that's about
getting water back into the ground if we
can through infiltration um if we can't
do that we'll be looking to try and put
it back to a water body so so water CL
through a river um ultimately we'll be
you know obiously trying to promote SS
and I know through the plan process
that's a you know key requirement now in
sort of Green Solutions and nature based
solutions to some of these these
challenges and then as a very last
result we may um agree to to control
thisch through a combin
network
so just I'm just very conscious of time
so as we said so so follow the recent
feedback we've held some intern what
have we've done different so we've held
some interal workshops I'm hoping you'll
start to recognize already that some of
the responses that we're making are more
detailed now um I'm really challenging
the team now to um to really sort of go
um a bit deeper in terms of the
challenges and then you will see that
you certainly see that going forward as
Richard said we held we held a work with
your officers um before Christmas we've
got another one line up at the beginning
of February to really start to um to to
to gain um
an understanding of each other's needs
and make sure that we you know what we
provide you is is is what we require
going forward um we will be making sure
we we put on some standard requirements
the standard requirements said just now
surface water um you know making sure
we've got efficiency challenges from a
water resource perspective um because
it's really important we do that and in
addition to that um you know we only
have obligation to take the roof the the
surface water from rof and driveways we
don't have the responsibility for the
highway so therefore we are trying to
work with Highway authorities to try and
sort of come up with
um functional solutions for them if you
like because obviously again that's a
bit of a challenge to us and we've got a
lot of things in place now with regards
to you know sub adoption and which you
recent legislation change make that
happen um but also some of the more
innovative solutions that I was with the
develop ear this week um talking through
some some um some interesting ideas
they've got around how they think they
can get water back into the environment
rather than through the traditional
roots and in addition to that sorry can
we come to the next slide which is the
last last slide but in addition to that
we've got large programs of taking
surface water out of our networks to
make capacity for growth so so we either
take it out as direct surface water or
alternatively out as as as what we know
is infiltration so therefore it's coming
in from the ground into into the pipes
and we'll do that by sealing pipes seing
systems to stop it from getting in on
that basis so just in terms of of of our
next steps um so we said few couple
times now we' previously engaged with
you we will continue to do that this is
another session line at 7 February um we
would like to come back we just come
back share a lot of information with you
not just around the planning but also
around you know our future plans um some
of the initiatives that we've already
got ongoing and we've got a session
lined up which we hope will be at the
beginning of March to to to for that to
happen and I'll be here alongside some
other colleagues to make that happen but
there's a list of the things that I
wanton be through that we're proposing
to share with you at that process hope
to give you a little bit more um Insight
in terms of the some of the things that
we we've got going on and then I think
the last just point one here is around
you know we recognize and we did
recognize and reflection some of the
comments that we had from the feedback
that we' had back you know and we we
started to do something about that to
make our responsive to planning
applications more informative CH we give
you guys the opportunity to make to um
you know
proper thank you thank you both Mr
Brenton was first thank you ch um yes
the planning situation um what
initiatives are you taking to get uh
householders to actually separate stor
water from their sewage or domestic
waste water because U myself we we built
two houses one 25 years ago it was a
quite simple process to just put all the
um storm water into a soak way because I
mean as you know B sits on a almost
vertical sedimentary rock structure and
it just drains away no problem really
however when we did our latest one which
was about three years ago yeah that's
it wasn't easy then not at all Builder
control officer said to me best thing
you can do is connect it all into the
sewer that's the easiest thing to do and
we did however since then I've now
chopped it all off you know it's now no
longer going down but there's an
opportunity there to get rid of a lot of
you know roof water and driveway water
if only householders had the incentive I
I haven't applied sat yet to get a
rebate on my um water bill but I
understand that was the case because we'
got it originally and I hope it is still
the case because otherwise I wasted me
money but I mean really I do feel that
there is
opportunity big developers got to sort
themselves out with their their Su at
least for private individuals there's a
lot of properties around that be very
suitable for soqu so so thank you a
really good question I think there's
probably a couple of things just in
terms of response so the first one is in
terms of the deduction and you're
absolutely right he in place so yes give
us the call um through the the building
center um I think your point is well
made one is difficult one in terms of
how we manage it that basis we do need
to get closer bu control offices because
an interesting you know concept and
almost that you know just put into the
sewer because the last thing that any of
us want is that basis what we also see
quite a lot of um and again this is this
is something we want to get closer to to
your Sal on is um around um parking for
example whereby we see a lot of people
converting what was a a lawn into a
widen parking area um you know taking
that increasing the airine just tapping
it into the system which causes some
problems what we know is urban Cree so
we build that arguably into our models
But ultimately we like to try and get
out in the first instance and therefore
um you know the challenge is there we do
need to get closer to to guys on the
branch understand how that that comes in
um it's an interesting concept and it's
not one I've necessarily got an answer
to you know but but it's certainly
something I'd be happy to take away
whether there is an incentive for us you
know over and Beyond the building bit um
to to look at but but you know standing
here it's not necessary I consider but
thank you point really
really Thomas
first just wonder you talked about um
dealing with sort of 30,000 plus
planning applications and you know
looking at what your network can
support how often would you say the
Southwest water actually object to
planning proposals particularly to the
larger ones so I think we looked um we
did a bit of review of this Before
Christmas obviously when we were doing
the reflection and it's somewhere
between about 8 and 10% of where we will
give substantive not but almost not
objections because we won't we won't
tend to object object but what we will
do is we will raise those concerns it's
not for us to to determine that we will
always try and do um you know to help
the the growth agenda recognizing and
just interesting talking to you know
listen to the NS stuff here talking
about you the need for hous you know so
we recognize our importance in that role
um but it's somewhere been between about
8 and 10% in terms of the ones we go
back with what we're now going finally
doing um is what we what what we found
is that there is a large proportion of
those that get a fairly Bland if
response at all and we need to close
that gap which which is absolutely a
priority for us so I've got some some
challenges internally to make that
happen but um and as you can imagine my
team are are understanding you know
trying to work they do that but that's
our challenge we will definitely be
doing
that Piper believe we had your hand up
thank you um uh thank you for coming and
giving the presentation um I just wanted
to say um a congratulations I think to
councelor Christie because um his motion
some time ago seems to have it might not
have been just that but it seems to have
instigated quite a response um and and
encouraged increase the asan with local
Authority fin departments is good good
to hear um I would say your surfus water
hierarchy uh system is quite commendable
and obviously L does tackle new build
but as um an Brenton alluded to I guess
it's the existing stock that's a major
problem
um my my main concern is probably what
were you doing before this all seems
staggeringly late um in the in in the
context of um an infrastructure that
obviously couldn't deal with what we had
or what was coming um
and I and I say that because I suppose
I'll cut for the chase you know the
public look at it and say all they can
see is so uh water companies o openly
admitting to being woefully inadequate
with the protection of our natural
resources having to admit
to
coverups and with the context of
shareholders taking lots and lots of
money and I know it's a simplistic view
but I think as a lowly counselor i' be
wrong not to raise the things that I
think all of Joe public think um but it
sounds like you are making strides to
improve things but i' stress that the
public are pretty
angry sest water and I hope more radical
approaches are taken and the money is
but you mention the word affordable
making these doing what you're saying
you're going to do but it has to be
affordable I think
um affordability
is not important to the public it's
you've got to get the job
done
thanks your point is well made and you
know as our Che ex would say any
pollution incident any overflow is is
one too many so we're really focused on
that and I think we've got to we' got to
also be better at telling the story if I
think about you know my career in the
war I the last 30 years uh cleaning up
Southern England so back 30 years ago a
lot of the discharges around the coast
were crew discharges weren't treated at
all so as a as a business we've we've
invested over 13 billion pounds uh
putting in secondary treatment right
around the coast and it's really good to
see that in in the southwest we've got
860 miles of Coastline a third of the
countryes and for the last three years
all of those bathing beaches have re
reached the bathing water standard which
is excellent and 99% of them are in the
good and excellent category however
you're absolutely right you know we've
got to work harder on score mile clo
that's why our business plan is doubling
in value to 2.8 billion and a third of
that business plan is all focused on
storm overflows so we want to get
handing glove with uh your your officers
and planning committees as well as make
those Investments and uh you know meet
the expectation that he's absolutely
right and out
there thank you counc hack it first and
then it was
C thank you chair um I've got a question
that relates to sheep wash and Buckland
Brewer principally both are Village
locations both have received a very
substantial amount of um planning in the
last five years and will increase in the
future in the case of sheep wash it's
going to have about 50% upli in housing
and buckin brew has five major sites
now in the case of sheepwash the parish
council were notified at the beginning
of this Century Millennium that there's
perhaps five years additional capacity
to build within the the area sheet
wash I presume due to the size of the
water treatment plant or it might be to
the main 4 in diameter sewer in the
village in the Main
Street how can they just refer to
standing advice how can you refer to
just standing advice going forward when
there was concern about minimal building
20 odd years ago thank you
so so absolutely apologies I'm not
familiar with the the particular areas
I'm more than happy to take them away we
did SP to Tom around the ability for
queries particular on a more localized
level on that basis so I think we need
to check on way really happy to for you
thank you before I come on to you c v
the the March meeting um we all have an
opportunity to put our questions in
writing an email foral however to these
gentlemen at that planning meeting of
which everyone obviously is willing is
welcome to attend so
Council okay just put
one sorry can you just speak you you you
said how much money was going to be
spent on these you improving things
could I just ask how much that is in
relation to southest Waters profit
because the public here and I maying
this informed that large shareholder
profits did and of paid out to
shareholders when and not much has been
going on improving in the infrastructure
and I just wonder if and I don't want to
be rude and suggest that green washing
is going on but
saying you 330 million I don't know in
the context of Southwest water and
Southwest water's profits and Southwest
water customers is that huge should we
be impressed should we say wow we can
sit down and not worry anymore just
asking no it's a very very good question
and and I think there probably a whole
whole Wes I could come back and try and
bring that to life for you I mean the
first thing is that our group is a is a
publicly listed company so it's one of
three water companies on the market and
we're we're probably one of the most
financially resilient we have low
gearing so we're not highly geared low
gearing and and through our uh
industry-leading customer sharees safe
system one in 14 of our customers are
shareholders so our our uh scrutiny that
we put around being PLC uh our dividend
policies and boards and the way we
govern the uh the business is really
transparent so I definitely invite
counselors to have a look at those
accounts and and you'll see that you
know this substantial uptick in
investment is really important at the
same time making sure we've got a really
financially resilient
business thank you councelor Andrews
star now let C Cod hun very quick just
to say do we have a date did I miss it
do we have a date for this meeting so I
just earlier today talking to SM it's
the first of March I think it'll be an
am meeting the latest we sort of
literally head with that in this
afternoon um So the plan I think first
first of March in the morning is is
soon as we know
we um
H he talked about reducing the average
number of spills to 20 per location per
year by
2025 um but you didn't say what that's
in comparison to so at present how many
do we have and how many locations is
that cross TD pleas because I expect
this that's quite High I I don't really
understand you give a number but it's
not in comparison to anything yes I
think big are there so I said this loely
terms of overarching num so we've
already made some significant
improvements so I think we were not NE
against but um we we've reduced spills
from something like 38 down to about 28
already so we've already made that
investment to make that happen in terms
of the number of of of of um spills
within torage I need to come back you we
get information I just need to come back
to you to something
dat but what we'll do is when we come
back in Mark we make sure that's
included within the presentation P thank
you got councel back
and
P thank
you
excuse specific questions about spills
outage or outrage we call them in West I
get a lot of questions from local
residents as a westw home board member
about what's happening through our
waterways and Coastal Waters he seems to
have no end of spillages um at M home um
and people want answers to this so I
won't press you now but I welcome the
opportunity of that invting for you for
the mar
meeting make sure we cover SPS in
general
but locations more than happy separately
thank thank you chair thank you for your
your uh F last Monday in the financial
times there was a report from about the
environment agency saying that you
miscalculated the drought in
2022 um can you reassure us that the
calculators were correct and that we are
not going to be short of water for the
future thank you I guess I need to be a
little bit careful because obviously you
know that that discussion is still going
on in terms of that that that disclosure
um in terms of and I guess I can speak
to a personal level so so at the end of
last summer I um I was in my control
room pulled in as part of a small team
to make sure that we um obviously make
sure maintain services and supplies
through all of our customers which which
we successfully managed to do um from a
water resource perspective there was
some challenges you know we had some
challenges in roord we also started some
challenges in cord which is our foral
and we've already invested a significant
amount of money um delivering projects
that that allow us now to have greater
resilience of how we move water around
around the regions so so you know I
stand Here the numbers so if you look
the the reservoir levels wrong we have
been helped by the current weather um
you know but our Reservoir levels are
significantly higher than they were at
the same time last year um and therefore
we are confident we will continue to
supply wholesome water to all our
customers however you know as and you'll
see from the um from Water Resource
Management plan you know that's up to
250 look ahead to make sure that we've
got all of the things that we need so
you you you may be aware we in corn
we're looking at the East anation plant
recogniz we've got a coastline you know
in the southwest that we can take
advantage j it brings us own challenges
in terms of treating that wion but you
know we are we are addressing that as we
speak so we've got significant
investment lined up not only now but
also going forward to make sure that we
can um maintain us serves thank you for
reply thank you chair c counc Mrs
Brenton and then last speaker is going
to be Council Le yes I must say I was
rather surprised to hear that you were
congratulating yourselves on how well
you were doing producing the pollution
when we hear of the continuous pollution
issues in South when just um a couple of
weeks ago um the issue is about
decanalization really are there any
plans for us have anything up there
because obviously we nearly um bit of a
just straight beyond the postp B
most um back in the summer but I can
remember when we had stand pipes in the
streets in in before your time pration
but even so it's still rationing water
the summer um are there any plans for
Des
salinization um up in this area and what
is the method of coping with purity of
water if you don't have clean water in
the sea because of some kind of spirit
issue so um building on the last
question and your question I think it's
fa to say that Ian personally LED lots
of projects last year to uh increase the
resilience of the water supply in de and
cor so I think with the projects lad
coming in quaries ha tore and others
we've increased the uh Supply in Devon
by 12% for more by 25% and we're
currently as many in the room will know
puring a destion solution for Cornwall
which will boost supplies by another
four to 5% but in our business plan what
we're also uh proposing to develop is a
new Reservoir scheme at ched 2 up in
Bristol and then with resilience through
the network and displacement through
West for of supplies into Deon so our
Water Resources management plan which is
a presentation in its own right
absolutely considers providing
sustainable water 25 years into the
future thank you C leather you're the
last speaker thank you chair yeah I'm on
the T District council's
plan and over the years Council chrisan
myself mentioned very often that we
never get any information from say
planning application oh yeah providing
the size of the pipe being connected in
from the development corresponds with
what their find that's about all we ever
get we did write the pl committee had a
letter sent to West W asking about the
capacity of the per treatment PL which
protes all the ways from this areas and
Bs to
BS the reply we had back was that is
commercially sensitive
information you got no competitor here
how is that commercially sensitive what
we wanted to know was all these
developments coming on online and
they're on the go has in the area we
wanted to know how many years capacity
is there 5 10 20 years and we should
have had an answer to that we didn't get
it and that just rubs us up I completely
understand that and apologies for that I
don't understand that standing here now
I don't understand that response and I
will go back and ask some questions when
I right back in the office tomorrow
because because you're right we we
should be able to that dat information
to you so please leave that with me
I thank you well thank you gentlemen for
that detailed report thank you very much
and I think I think I'd like to Echo
what councelor Piper said thank you very
much to councelor Christie for
highlighting this issue and bringing it
Forward because without without his
persistence I don't think this meeting
would have been quite as interesting
thank thank you all very
much okay item 10 is the shared
Prosperity fund investment plan for 2425
Pages 22 to 32 um question can come
forward with us
you
right uh good evening councelors um uh
sure I'm try and keep this nice and
brief in terms of the intro uh for many
people it's already been a long day
after CNR this morning and now there
lots of uh items still to come on the
agenda um I think that since we brought
the share Prosperity fund investment
plan back in July 2022 there's been
significant amount of change and what
we're now looking to focus on with this
review is actually focusing on delivery
we know that since then we've had the
15.6 million pound funding wward for the
appor clean Maritime Innovation Center
which has changed a significant amount
of where our efforts need to be and
where we're aware those opportunities
will be moving forward we've had the
bord Regeneration board the great
carington regeneration um strategy we
have the northern Devon culture strategy
and it's now about also prepping and
using this funding for opportunities
ahead such as loving up partnership such
as the forthcoming cultural development
funds are being encouraged to prepare
for by the Arts
Council and making sure therefore
that this funding actually has a far
larger Legacy especially at time when
there's an enormous amount on but again
being honest very limited capacity to
make sure that we're targeted rather
than scatter gun all over the place so
case now of hopefully moving forward and
delivering the items that are listed in
there which I can have approved already
in various different guises and creating
some positive stories um from the thank
you questions M
hes um yeah I don't know if I'm getting
confused but there's an item here E7
support practice travel enhancement um
and then then there's some tables
showing which which page are you on oh
sorry page
23 in the boxes there then later
revision boxes E7 doesn't appear does
Chris could explain
that always nice to down those ones I'm
straight I think
there's difference of page numbering to
see
you yeah okay so kind of um if you look
at the top of page
23 what that's indicating is that those
were the items approved in
2022 well um what we've then looked to
do I don't believe that E7 and featured
within the investment plan for 20 uh 4
25 which is why does come up within the
listings included for
Orion somewhat disappointing thank
you any other speakers BR you got hand
than yes um it's page 26 um e33 support
for economically inative people um no
figures for economically inative people
and the Strand do not align with the
objective of improve employment and
skill quality um I'm not quite sure what
that means does it mean you just don't
have the figures or there aren't any
economically inactive I unemployed
people in this in this community
strangely um and this is something that
we do work on with department for work
pensions
um the greater issue that DWP actually
tells me is issues of underemployment
and people having multiple
roles and that is often generated from
some of those kind of um lower skilled
seasonal roles where people have to D
between different fills again though
coming back to where we have the
opportunities and where we have strands
of work that actually have been kind of
uh approved by counselors kind of in
various different forms already is
making sure that actually we can now
deliver on those what we cannot do I
wish I could is solve every single
problem um there is unemployment but
where we've been tasked s of with
pushing is actually grow the quality of
jobs are out there grow the scale of
good quality particular kind of focused
on areas such as Net Zero within blue
and green economies moving forward job
to mean that actually we're addressing
all of these issues over longer term
rather than just creating shortterm ex
Solutions now but I ABS not saying
there's no unemployment but it's just a
case of making sure that we've been
looking at where we could have Maximum
Impact right now we work way can I just
clarify so basically you're saying it's
just not very good in
thought need support that then because
we all know that you have a a lower than
average skills base um so I find I find
it's really a bit contradictory
really that um you you know you're not
saying it doesn't align with your
objective I think when you look at all
of these things we can make everything
align um big issue
oh when you're talking about one of the
districts in the council as highlighted
by leveling up District in the country
as highlighted by leling up AR that with
lowest average earnings with serious
challenges around
competitiveness we are fully and acutely
aware of the kind of array of kind of
interlocked challenges um why we're
trying to push down certain
[Music]
lines but there there's not one kind of
magic solution to any of these problems
hope this why by making the most of
these funding streams and by attracting
other funding streams in help deliver on
that longer
term that we will make progress across
all of them M Piper thank you chair um
thank you Chris for a easily
understandable report it's a subject
that I feel like I've come into as a new
counselor um trying to learn quickly but
reports seemed pretty straightforward
and it's about delivering what is
deliverable getting on with things um
which I like um I'd also just just like
to take the opportunity to thank
um officers for putting time and effort
into the project in h the manner offices
H has got it act together a little bit
maybe um to highlight a specific area
that we can do something in you we
haven't got a wider regeneration board
like B
um and torington and maybe that makes
things simpler um but we're
also um thankful to be following in
their footsteps um and the case in point
being I actually took time to go to the
Castle Hill workhub to see what good
work's been done there and how uh you
know that's something that Holly get
fire to and I say slightly tongue and
cheek that I see torent and workhub and
Hol of these manner offices are in the
same um bracket um with the same capital
expenditure obviously with them so far
ahead of us hope um a good chunk of that
would be going to the manor offices and
I look around I know I'm quite
surrounded by torington people so I'll
shut up thank
you come I just follow up on that active
travel thing if it's not in this boxes
later on as being taken out is it not
possible to give put it in back in and
give the reasons for why you
included the first thing I will say
counc is there still remains an active
TR travel um budget from 22 23 to in
report that's I know the working group
have been looking Su spend so that has
been sat kind of there that's from the
sh Prosperity funds uh investment plan
so there is still money there for the
active transport active travel sorry uh
group to uh Spain okay thanks okay
James you speak just I'm quite happy to
propose recommendations okay someone
second
yeah
second that's a lot all in favor please
show thank
you
question okay item 11 on your agenda is
council tax legislation changes second
homes Pages 33 to 45 on your agenda and
Gordon is going to present the report
thank
you thank you chair so item 11 details
two particular changes to the operation
of counil tax the first one is the time
period of which the 100% premium is
introduced on empty properties and the
second one is introducing a 100% premium
on second home owners this is the second
time this paper essentially has been
before you all um the first time was
back in October this has had to be
represented because of the delays in the
original legislation receiv be the the
Royal
assem now the purpose behind this
legislation is to bring more homes back
into use and to convert more second
homes into primary
residences in a sense then it's to meet
some of the dysfunctions of the existing
housing
market
if you notice the table on page
34 this shows so the middle table this
is where it says theoretical additional
income this this provides the potential
the potential additional funds available
to us to meet some of those challenges
within the hand market so you can re see
it just within porridge that's over2
million pound and of course across the
county of Dev you can multiply it that
significantly members will also be aware
that we already put in significant
amount of money to meet some of those
challenges for example with intent re
accommodation that webly spend every
million pounds a year but thank you
chair this is about essentially bring
more hes into use converting more second
hes into primary res Amplified
additional funds to meet
maret wiwi to me move recommendation
chair you proposing that second by C
Newton all in favor please
sh
[Music]
you item 12 Constitution Constitution
update Pages 46 to 76 I believe Stacy is
present rep thank you CH so again this
is a a technicality really um in 2019 we
had a management restructure
on a temporary basis and then that was
made permanent um with the different
departments being divided and between
the senior
managers we always meant to update the
Constitution but then Co hit so it's
just to actively reflect um the
Departments that are under the relevant
senior managers um effectively ended up
with sha having nothing underneath him
um but in practice and every practice he
has so it's just it's just to record
that put housing under me um and yeah to
ensure as head of committies in place he
has planning building control Etc
Underneath
Him
James recommendation happy to Second it
from the chair all in favor please
show
you
item 13 is the halfe treasury management
Pages 77 to
[Music]
84 thank you chair item 13 just gives
the council the operat to gives us the
opportunity to report back to court
Council on the operation of the treasury
management
policy you'll notice that we it details
the the policy that was previously
agreed by members so apologies if some
of a wording is slightly historic by for
example referring to environment say but
this was a policy that was agreed and
the purpose of the paper is to show our
compliance with it the main body of the
paper also details some of the key
pressures and some some of some of the
key dependencies of it so for example it
describes a movement in interest rates
um in recent years and months and it
also s our potential income from
interest in this year and members will
get an update of pbr3 as well in
that so thank you CH I'm happy to report
the comply with the
policy
here yeah I'll move that sorry
hes ethical Investments yeah you got
it your predecessor us to um section out
um the E investment bid bar Investments
I can't see it on this report can you
just tell us what your position is
please given that interest rates going
not considerably while hope that there
would be an earning you know some sort
of allocation
to by
now yeah thank you chair page 85 shows
our list of current Investments um so
you've got that details there and it
also describes our effable investment
policy so every time we do look to
invest cash out we do see if there are
any um institutions
would hasn't yet been um well the Box
showing the Investments or these funds
that we used to have something actually
so specifying
which which fund um we could investments
in I think it slight seems slightly
different from what we used to get so I
can't identify an e investment in list I
miss something think we
used yeah I'm not aware that there's
anything being presented now good what's
being presented previously so so we
haven't got the E Investments
moment we do always look to see if we do
the market when out this is because it
doesn't comply with the regulations is
that right it's partly the regulations
it's partly our internal policy because
we we've said that we're not going to um
foro more than 20 basis points for every
million pounds that we lend out as an
operation we still haven't reached
that I can discuss it with you
further second
your don't proposing it's been seconded
all in favor pleas
shell unanimous again thank
you moving swiftly on to item 14 polling
District of polling places review 23 as
Pages 86 to
95 uh thanks chair so every four years
we require to undertake a review of our
polling districts and polling places um
and this uh report summarizes the
results of that review uh we undertook a
a period of consultation between 21st
and November 23 and closed on the 2nd of
January 24 there were two responses to
that consultation received one from a
great torron resident expressed the
opinion that poing stations are okay and
one from councelor leather which uh
flagged up anally which has since being
corrected so the list of polling station
and polling places are listed in
appendix
be
letter yeah just briefly thanks for
putting North G back where it should
have been all along the only thing is
the register picked up the other they
still got North Dean video it say why is
that I don't know it says North de
Norther we can take a look at that it's
moved to the northern okay the
recommendation I'll second it from the
chair all in favor please
sh Anonymous thank
you okay item 15 is to answer a question
submitted under procedural rule A9 and
we've got one question receed from
councelor Brenton C Annie Brenton Mrs
Brenton thank
you answer question I don't think be a
to get an answer to it yet it's such a
simple question it's do the 36 elected
members of this Council have any input
into the configuration of the I'm not
talking about the um software
application I'm talking about the things
like archiving for instance it's very
difficult to get any information about
previous full Council meetings Beyond
may this year and I would like to find
some of that out um of course I could go
down to p a new
or but I thought that's what going to be
avoiding um it is best practice for when
a substantial group of people who are
employed in an organization and have you
know a reasonable amount of St they may
not be well I don't know at one time you
can't the real reason why it dis here
but maybe that's not the case anymore
but um that they actually did have some
input into the way things worked and it
seems to me that these have quite a
cumbersome program aspect and I'm sure
that a working group could come up with
some of the hicups and remove them and
so that was my question um I'm reading
the answer and I'm taking that as a no
but I'm not sure because I didn't ask
about the history and I didn't criticize
the fact that we have these um uh iPad
which seems to be Ro implication I was
just asking whether a small group of
this 36 member council could
highlight either hit us in the system or
improve because there are some very
clever people here much clever than me
and I'm not even suggesting that I
should be on this group before but you
know and I'm sure they could improve the
situation somewhat and so that was my
question and I don't understand why it
can't be answered I think really but but
it has apparently been I'm taking it to
the no so there's no inut from counsel
into this thing we just use it it's
imposed on it and we have to
well it's not very good it's
not can can I just ask around the room
are there any other coers that have a
particular issue with the way that the
uh the iPad system works all the all the
way that it the way that it
operates yes and that all those that do
have a particular issue with
it and councelor James you put your hand
up I've seen you had an officer help you
many many a time and loads of others as
well I'll be honest put his hand up you
certainly will um so there appears to be
a number Tom you're one of our Wizards
on this surely if there is a if there is
an issue anyone that's that has
difficulty in accessing information as
come Brenton suggesting can't they come
down sit in your office with you and one
of the other off officers and just give
a bit of onetoone tuition to actually
sort the problem out
yes with my team and also the IT team I
would have thought it's as simple as
that yeah I'm sorry but that's not what
I'm you've got an answer to your
question no we don't have a specific
input but I would imagine if you're if
you're anything like me I'm a bit of a
dinosaur on on the computers and I think
you know if the if if we got the
necessary expertise to show us exactly
how to overcome the the problems that
we've got that would probably do
it I just wanted to say I don't don't
feel that I have a a situation that
needs truition i i i my understanding of
what um councelor Brenton is saying is
that she feels that there could be some
things that make the use of the iPad
easier for us and I think that that is
true I think that we have a a barrage of
emails Every Day from external companies
offering course I mean that's just one
thing I think of right now and I'm
thinking is there anything that we could
do to improve that so that we're not
wading through all these things and we
can come and you know I don't know how
far the the stuff on modg goes back but
I've I've never tried to go back to a
historic um minutes or or decisions for
example but if that is an issue then
could we could we come up with a way of
communicating and improving we're not
asking if we're not asking people
regularly is there something that you
think that we could do to make this
better I don't think it's about tuition
I think it's about just making it more
intuitive for what we're trying to do
Tom can you you've got that can you
arrange a meeting and send the invites
out to all counselors with the time and
date so that anyone can come down and
they can they can talk about the issues
and hopefully resolution I I agree with
the you know the the emails that you get
from outside bodies and your advice to
me is don't open anything that isn't
coming from for and that's tend to be
what I what I
do so you will
that is a fundamental
question because when our residents
email us that is from outside Tor well I
answer them obviously if it's a from a
private
individual where the dang because I get
emails from people proposing to be
somebody when they are not and we have
to be very very careful but we get lots
of emails with these like almost like a
yellow box on the and it's from from
some government
Department several times your email was
not that's what happens when you get
HED okay item 16 we have no
[Music]
petitions so item 17 one notice of
motion has has been received from
councelor Mrs Andy Brenton and the mo
the motion proposes that TDC adopts the
LGA model code model councelor code of
conduct the chair of Standards Council
of back has agreed that this will be an
item on the standards agenda for the
meeting on the 28th of February members
are unable to adopt a new policy without
a report being presented to a formal
committee so I would suggest that once
it's been through standards
and you've come up with a recommendation
then come back with a view to adopting
it but I take the sentiment I think we
should do it that's BR did you the
constition I have the right to propose
this motion I haven't suggested you have
I'm just making a statement now this
frustrated at all anyway um obviously
this is the second time of proposing
this and actually it's even more gerain
and important now because the the um
local government um
proposals The Local Government Model con
code of conduct deals with issues that
we haven't got in our present Cod on
particularly respect of other counselors
which we had an incident of last
month um and that you don't make
personal remarks about other counselors
and you don't um cause them offense
that's quite important I think and so
that's one of the things that we need to
have I would have this but the other
thing is because it's much more updated
than our Cod G it deals with face tace
meetings online telephone or telephone
meetings on Zoom written
communication verbal communication or
nonverbal communication and also most
importantly because I know the chair did
remember that he was on YouTube this
time but he actually said something that
went on YouTube that I was very offended
by last meeting in electronic and Social
Media communication posts statements and
comments on the media now there's an
awful lot more in here about the
standards the councilor should observe
T's had a long running situation only
quite recently and I know this because
the the person concerned used to phone
up my husband and he wasn't there and I
answered the phone he he tell me all
about it that's how I know about it and
it you know really it was clear that
there wasn't a clarity about what
council of conduct should be so this is
an important document and we should
adopt it we should treat everybody with
this respect and we shouldn't compromise
the authority of anyone who works for or
on behalf of the local authorities
there's loads and loads of stuff in here
that actually isn't on our code of
conduct but it's very concise actually
that's
it not we're adopting um a 500 page
document or anything and actually the
the previous uh situation where there
was no respect for the Constitution
there was no respect for the you of the
standards the standards of to council
and the debate only proves to me that we
do need this because the people involved
with both one was an experienced
councelor and the other was somebody
who' been a lay member on the standards
committee for heaven knows how and yet
they did not obey the government's RWS
they didn't obey the
Constitution so don't tell me we don't
need this because we
do I propose this is adopted now at this
Council I second
speak on it
chair sorry yeah I second it I I want to
speak on
it um we need to clear this up and we
need to do it tonight I hear what you
say about the standard board the
standards committee are not balanced
they don't have the constitutional right
to decide this every member is affected
by the code of conduct we should all
take a vote on it we should all sign up
to it that's that's the truth of the
matter and if that means susp mention of
standing orders and I I would move that
it's up to you CH do you think it
requires that or no because really we
could decide this now at this
meeting well I think the point that I
made um a few minutes ago and I'm I'm
actually in agreement with what it is
you're proposing in theory but it hasn't
yet been discussed by the standards
committee I hear what you're saying and
once when it has been discussed and
recommended by the standards committee
No Doubt it will come back and it will
probably be adopted I don't see the
point of do why should it be discussed
by the standard Bo it's a very limited
group of people who who are actually as
I say they're not balanced Poli they
could come up with a decision which
doesn't reflect the the whole view of
the council no we should be decided this
whole Council should decide it and they
can do it now we don't it's an LGA thing
for heaven's sakes it's not you know
mystery stuff here this is
straightforward the code of conduct and
I think I don't see why we has to shove
it off to standard board what is the
purpose that okay well it's being your
proposing it coun Brenton it's been in
second sorry point of order chair I was
just going to take it to the vote that's
all just a point of order um we're been
asked to discuss and approve something
that hasn't appeared on the agenda and
without going through it and having due
reflection on our individual position
positions I don't think we can decide
this tonight and I'd be much happier
that it went through the standards
committee CH I mean I've got the conduct
in front of me part five chapter one I
put it in this sit comes up it's here
it's before my eyes I've already adopted
it am I have I not I can be
disrespectful now because I haven't
adopted on the on the Constitution
already it's already in the
Constitution part five chapter one as
I've got it but let me just bring Stacy
in for a second and then you I think um
All Points obviously have been made
tonight are valid um but when we're
talking about the Constitution full
Council delegates certain
responsibilities down to certain
committees standards is is is one of
these delegations now it will come back
to full Council once standards have
major recommendations and also Ely be up
to full Council to make that decision
but that will be a full report and with
the code of conduct um nothing against
the model code of conduct it's already
been discussed with the chair it is on
the the standards um agenda but the
point is yes we do already have respect
within our um code of conduct all codes
of conduct are based on the Nolan
principles the seven noan
principl um the LGA one it's a good code
it expands our but it doesn't
fundamentally change where we are but I
do I do I do think it's wrong um for two
reasons one because this has been
delegated down to standards or Wan
standards haven't considered it and two
because as councelor hacket has just
said there is no report in front of
members and members are being asked to
adopt something that they haven't
considered so I think it's it's on the
next standards agenda in February
standards will review it discuss it and
then it will come back to for Council to
make an ultimate decision ision on
whether they want to adopt the code or
not on a point of order that is that if
that is what is being proposed that
needs to be voted on you can't just
shove it off to standards this CC have
they have to make a decision that that's
the progress that they wish to make
because that wasn't done
that just to say that the constitution
already says that this is within stand
jurisdiction it it's like circumventing
a committee to go to full Council and
and that's would be happening
here yeah thank you
um I don't think we're not there's no
immediate Panic or rush for goodness
sake let's not be bounced into something
there's a lot of people around this
table or this forum who actually would
like to hear or see in more detail we
have a perfectly well-formed committee
whose job is to look at those things
they don't make a decision they just go
into it in more detail which any of us
can attend if we want to to and then
they bring it back to us with
recommendations we will still make that
decision ultimately so I don't think we
should be pushed and SEC and thirdly on
our rules and procedure I think as a
notice of motion we shouldn't be
debating this anyhow it should only be
the proposer and second and this should
not be going forward without proper
debate which we can do when the
standards committee have made their
recommendations and bring them to to us
in a proper measured way thank you
coun well I I don't see that the mot the
not of motion is going to be withdrawn
but it's being proposed and it's being
seconded so let's take it straight to
the vote whether we're going to support
C Brenton motion all those all those in
Support also if it's going to standards
this noce motion and which is what
you're saying then it has to have an
amendment and I and I have to agree with
that Amendment um a61 that must be voted
on after uh proposing and secondly if an
amendment to motion is proposed it must
be carried by a vote to approve that
Amendment then that becomes a
substantive motion and must be voted on
again and the withdrawal of a written
motion which is what you're asking me to
do which I'm not going to do I think it
is important and amazes me the most
counselors who came onto this in May on
councel in May went to the standers
training and Beth Evans the very
competent
trainer suggested to everybody that they
read the local government model code of
conduct he was very surprised that we
hadn't adopted it so I find that this
excuse that oh I haven't seen it when
you might have been on the council for
ever such a long time I don't know but
um you know oh you haven't seen the lgm
on Code of Conduct when it's a standard
thing that's recommended in Council of
Standards training I find quite bizarre
but the point is that I believe you've
got to follow the governance of this
Council you've got to follow the rules
of debate and the Constitution and that
is what have to happen if a noted the
motion is proposed in second it has to
be voted or you have to go through all
the rest of the BR that's just what I'm
trying to do
I said you weren't go I said you weren't
going to withdraw it so we'll go to the
vote you've proposed it councelor
Brenton a seconded it all those in
support of councelor Brenda's motion
please please
show have you counted
them all
against voted down
29 an abstention sorry
exension
yes James you inating something to me I
understand
sorry well I didn't vote because I'm I'm
confused with this because I've got to
admit I agree with councelor Brenton
on disagree why
not before or
P I just don't see it seems to
be which we will be adoped there's no
argument about that but it shouldn't I
don't like delegated stand
necessary well I suppose the standards
committee will debate it they'll come
back with a report with probably with a
recom recation that we that we adopt
that well we voted on we've done
that chair just confirm the result the
vote it was two for 27 against and one
exstension thank
you okay item 18 and 19 is exclusion of
the public as a remainder of the meeting
contains exempt confidential
information so I propose we go into part
two second Toby yeah all in favor please
show
[Music]
anys any
abstentions 26 for against chair thank
you okay item 20 is operational Services
reoc sorry